the refugees left ukraine in freezing
conditions some now need different
clothes others have nothing
yulia says guards on the train made them
leave their suitcases behind so more
people could be crammed into the
carriages
i really need these shoes she says i
wouldn't have to take charity if it
wasn't for the war
there's no shortage of things being
donated but three weeks after russia's
invasion and it's not just clothes toys
and food that the refugees need
there's an accommodation crisis the
polls are even planning to turn a former
complex used by russian diplomats into
emergency housing
prices are rising and terry from essex
is worried about where his family will
stay his workmates had a whip round to
help fund his flight so he could be
reunited with his ukrainian wife and son
now waiting for their travel documents
if i don't get it by friday then
i'm strapped for cash for hotels
i have got people i can call in uk and
they can try to get some money emergency
money together
but i'm not that type of person
sisters anastasia and lubov are moving
hotels after the price of theirs doubled
overnight as a child lubov fled from
crimea when it was invaded by the
russians now just turned 18 her sister
has come from london to help her get a
visa and is worried about her safety
that's why i'm staying here with her
right now because there is no way i'm
leaving my 18 years old sister in warsaw
for hell knows how long
three million refugees have crossed into
neighboring countries but there are
reports of women and children going
missing prompting calls for more to be
done to safeguard them who do you now
trust
who's actually offering you the right
service who's actually offering you the
right support it is such a worry it's
great that people have opened up their
homes around the world but how do we
know that those are really in really
good intentions
this is the fastest growing flow of
refugees in europe since world war ii
now the authorities are trying to keep
up with the good will and support
desperately needed by so many driven
from their homes lisa holland sky news
warsaw